[Music]
thank you for being here
thank you for having me congratulations
on your show people really like this
probably how do you how do you like
being the B in apartment 23 I love it
you love playing this character I am
owning it I have a flask that says
Kristen the [ __ ] Ritter right I won in
my parking spot to say the [ __ ]
I'm just owning it my good friend told
me that [ __ ] stands for being in total
control of herself oh that's very cool
oh I'm owning it right well I think one
of the nice things too is it you're
you're getting to be known I think it'd
be sort of liberating if your character
is a [ __ ] or you know kind of tough and
did I mean it'd just be liberating
because people know you that way you
know oh my god now when I'm walking down
the street people are yelling like hey B
now you do and B which is better than
[ __ ] or hi I liked you when you choke
on your vomit and died here
Breaking Bad people come up to you and
say I get that a lot I love the part
when you choked on your vomit yeah great
know that Wow
that's right Oh creepy yeah like that it
was a good scene powerful now a big part
of this show sort of revolves around
your characters dating life does it
resemble your dating life at all
no on the show I make out with like five
guys a day mm-hmm
you know she's kind of a [ __ ] can you
say that on TV you just did I think you
can I don't know if my producer is just
on the phone getting a reservation at a
restaurant you know said [ __ ] 12 times
yeah
the difference I think it's like a [ __ ]
man I don't care no you know in real
life I have an affinity for for cute
young boys that like to get out and
seize the day for me there's nothing
worse than a grumpy old man oh so you do
not you're not one of those woman that
likes the older guy no not really I'm
when I was like 22 I was lusting after
Zac Efron when he was on Summerland how
old was he then like nine just leads
into my next question really so but you
were you like a younger younger lad yeah
I don't like grumpy old man that liked
to you know sit on the couch and watch
TV with the blinds closed it's not my
thing okay you just described me to a
tee well if it makes you feel any better
my friend who I brought with me today
told me that I should sit on my hands
because I might want to pinch you're
very cute but has everybody seen it it's
high and tight it's up there
[Applause]
where's your friend okay no that's funny
that she would say that because I've
often been told there's no but there I
don't have anybody I noticed what did
you have to mention that why couldn't
you just go along I got to get implants
or something